soccer's biggest stars are speaking out
after an entire girls team was benched
because someone thought one of the
players was a boy eight-year-old milli
Hernandez and her youth club were
disqualified from a weekend tournament
in Nebraska reports say someone
complained that a boy was playing on the
girls team vladimir duthiers of our
streaming network cbsn is here with
reaction from the family and soccer
organizers lad good morning good morning
Millie Hernandez is good at soccer good
enough to play on an 11-year old team at
only 8 years old but unfortunately it
wasn't her talent that has people
talking this morning it's her appearance
confuse parents of a Nebraska girl's
youth soccer team gathered for meeting
Monday evening trying to figure out how
tournament officials allegedly mistook
one of their players for a boy my own
brother he said it's only because the
looks they like when they look at me
they think I'm aboard but I'm really not
eight-year-old Millie Hernandez and her
family say her team was disqualified
from a weekend tournament after
organizers informed their coach she was
listed as a boy on the team's roster the
president of the tournament said that we
made our decision and we wouldn't change
it we had an insurance card and then we
had a paper from when she was five and I
said that female 1 Oh both of them a
report in the Omaha world-herald says
someone first alerted officials that
they believe Millie was a boy
and although organizers didn't believe
she was a boy listing a male player on a
girls roster is a violation of
tournament rules Kasim Costa mantas did
this to little girl her coach Mario
Torres said a little girl of 8 years old
there's no way to justify the mistake in
a statement the Nebraska State Soccer
Association said while they did not
oversee the tournament we recognized
that our core values were simply not
present and we apologize this needs to
be a learning moment for everyone
involved hey Millie Hernandez Abby
Wambach here some of soccers biggest
female stars showed support for
Hernandez including World Cup winner Mia
Hamm and two-time Olympic gold medalist
Abby Wambach you can do anything you
want to do and you can be anything you
want to be and guess what you can look
like whatever you need to look like to
do it we reached out to turn
organizer Springfield soccer club but we
have not yet received the reply we were
told a number of other players on
Millie's team want to cut their hair in
support of their teammate but they're
waiting for permission from their
parents that's solidarity solidarity
solidarity united we stand that's nice
nice ending to that story thing I think
you glad